[Music]
hello everyone
we are going to continue our discussion
of
the energy methods chapter uh with this
discussion of the first law of
thermodynamics now it may seem a little
bit uh surprising to
many of you that why in a course of
advanced mechanics of solids
we are going back to uh
thermodynamics so believe it or not
uh in the entire development of
mechanics
uh thermodynamics plays a very very
important role now this may not be
apparent from the from the ideas that we
developed during our undergraduate
studies
where subjects like thermodynamics fluid
mechanics and heat transfer
are taught
almost uh in isolation
from subjects like mechanics uh
mechanics of solids or mechanics of
materials
elasticity and so on but uh there is
a very very important
consideration of thermodynamics within
mechanics in fact
the the proper systematic theories
of mechanics cannot be developed
it simply cannot be developed without
the proper consideration
of thermodynamics all right so if you
ever
go on to uh do a higher studies
you will inevitably have to study a
course on continuum mechanics and there
you will see that
how important the the considerations of
thermodynamics
is anyway for our present purposes we
are not going to
to go into such detail but we will have
to consider
uh at least the first law of the
thermodynamics and the
and the consequences of it okay so uh
so usually we know from our
undergraduate studies that the first of
thermodynamics basically tells us that
the total work done by the external
forces
uh when added
to the total heat transfer given by q
into a body that should be equal
to the change in the
the change in the internal energy
and the change in the kinetic energy
okay so uh
please do not think right away that this
u is the potential energy or anything
like that okay so this right now
is the internal energy okay so change in
the internal energy
and this is heat transfer to the body
now in a variational sense we can write
this we can rewrite this as
now please note that if
we considered this change in internal
energy referred to some datum then we
did not keep
on writing this delta so this variation
the variational operator will take care
of it
so in the subsequent developments we
will just be using this
delta u now
uh for the kind of situations that we'll
be dealing with here
uh we'll be mostly interested in
adiabatic processes
okay
for which our delta q
is going to be zero because an adiabatic
process is one
in which the there is no heat transfer
to the body
all right next for a body that is in
static equilibrium
there is no change in the kinetic energy
of the body
okay so delta k is equal to zero so of
course our
the first variation of delta k that is
also equal to zero
so what we are left with really is
delta w e is equal to
delta u so the first variation of the
work done by the external forces
that is equal to the first variation of
the internal energy
mind you only for the specialized case
which we are considering here
that the uh that that's an adiabatic
process whatever the changes is going on
it's an adiabatic process
and the body is in static equilibrium of
course uh in our in our previous lecture
we have already been considering the
static equilibrium case when we
talked about the application of the
principle of virtual work
to a deformable body so this is very
much consistent with that
development okay so uh
so what we what we can rewrite this as
uh
so what we can do is this internal
energy we can rewrite this as
in terms of the the internal energy
density per unit volume
so that
this is u naught dv so this is internal
energy per unit volume
per unit volume and we can
can of course take this first variation
within the integration sign
okay so it is this form which we'll be
using subsequently
now next we are going to discuss the
potential energy
and you will see slowly how all of these
apparently disparate concepts
they tie in together okay as we keep on
developing our theory you'll see how
these things
i mean apparently right now they seem
quite disparate
uh disjointed but you'll see how they're
nicely connected
okay so
so i hope there should not be any undue
uh
apprehensions about the considerations
of the potential energy unlike the first
law of thermodynamics because
in a mechanics course you're all
familiar with the considerations of
potential energy
and you all know this to a certain
extent
the the underlying concepts nevertheless
we'll just recap it
in the language that we want for our
subsequent developments
so first of all what we say is that a
mechanical system is said to be
conservative
uh if the virtual work corresponding to
a virtual displacement of the system
completely around any closed path
and that's a very important concept it
must be around a closed path
and that's zero okay so mechanical
system
is said to be conservative
if the virtual the virtual work
associated with the virtual
displacements so
so i'm not writing the entire thing
although all these uh statements
and sitting formal nice way is already
present in our lecture notes
uh so if the virtual work associated
with the closed path
is zero right
now beyond what we because i mean you
know this thing
even from your high school physics
studies
but what we're going to say something
new about it is that
it could be conservative the mechanical
system could be conservative
in two senses the first is the static
sense
and the second is the kinetic sense so
conservative
in two sense
first is the static sense
and then the kinetic sense
so when we say it is static sense so
basically when the virtual displacements
uh they are executed
with infinite small speed okay so the
virtual displacements
they are executed with
at infinitesimal speed
and when the virtual displacements are
not necessarily
when the virtual displacements are not
necessarily
executed with inventional speed
we say that it is conservative in the
kinetic sense
okay so just a subtle point of
difference between the two
now uh let us consider the virtual work
associated only with the external forces
now if it so happens that such a virtual
work
okay so let's say the virtual work uh
associated with the external forces
so if
this thing is independent of the path
independent of path
what that basically means
is that independent of path means
the external work done will be only and
only dependent
on the terminal configurations that is
the initial configuration the final
configuration
okay so basically what means is that it
is dependent on the terminal
configurations
right so in in that in such a situation
what we say that
the external forces are conservative
and in such a case this w e
it can be expressed as a point function
okay now some of you have gone through
the previous lectures
will your brain will immediately go back
to the concept of the work function and
i'll discuss about that
immediately so before that i'll just
write this
that this w e can be represented as
in terms of a potential okay
so
where the dependence is on this x
representing the final configuration
we do not write the the dependence
explicitly on the initial configuration
because that only adds an additive
constant
okay so for support for changes that is
that doesn't really matter
okay it's like the consideration of a
data
now uh earlier we had talked about the
work function
so there uh we had to talk about the
work function in terms
or uh we had to define it in in set
theoretic terms
saying that it was the least upper bound
for for two configurations uh of concern
and there we had made a distinction
between the work done the
in general what could be a path
dependent work done
and the work function now as we have
written it
you note that if indeed our external
forces are conservative
okay so this happens if the external
forces are conservative
or we say that if such a thing happens
then the external forces are
conservative
so now our w
e it is independent of path which means
that if
if we are indeed working under such
circumstances that the external forces
are conservative that the w
is independent of path then the work
done
the virtual work done that is indeed
itself the work
function and in such a situation
naturally
because it is only dependent on the
initial and the final configuration
we can define it in terms of a potential
okay so had this been path dependent
then such a representation in terms of a
potential so where this
please note that this ve it is the
is the potential energy i mean
the potential energy of which will uh
enable us to obtain this w e
okay uh and this is this is referred to
as the point function
okay so very specifically this is the
potential energy
associated uh with the external forces
this is a point function
it's a point function and it is
the potential energy
of external forces
okay so up
as you can see the the concept of the
potential energy
it emerges in a nice and clean fashion
if we if we
set up our definitions like this okay so
uh first of all we are considering this
antenna mechanical system to be
conservative then we are
uh we are thinking about only the
external forces
uh when the external forces are
conservative we are considering this
virtual work
it is independent of path it is
dependent on terminal configurations
which has a direct connection
which means that the work done has a
direct connection with the work function
or it is the work function itself and
because the work function
is just dependent on the terminal
configurations we have this
equivalent representation in terms of a
point function
uh which is nothing but the potential
energy of the
external forces so there's a nice smooth
transition to the
concept in absolutely the same fashion
we can have
now we can consider the work done due to
internal forces
and here also if it so happens that it
is
if it turns out to be independent of
path then
again it is dependent only on the
terminal configurations
and again we'll have the wi
to be equal to so
any work done for or two such
configurations
uh with the with the internal forces
conservative
the internal forces conservative uh will
have this uh
equivalent representation in terms of a
point function
which is nothing but the potential
energy
of internal forces
sorry about this little bit of it
clutter here
try to fix it okay
now we have considered these two things
separately uh
suppose we had to consider this together
then
if both the internal and external forces
are
conservative
both internal
and external
forces are
conservative then
in the total virtual work
that is w e plus w i
uh that is the total w
that will be given by
another point function okay
so where again you note that we are only
representing
this x denoting the final configuration
and not explicitly writing the
dependence on the initial configuration
with the understanding that for
variational
purposes uh that initial configuration
will only add an additive constant so it
will
not really come into the picture so and
the important thing to note here is that
this is a point
function referred to as the potential
energy uh associated with both the
internal and the external forces
and of course it must be true that this
is
the this pi okay so this is the greek
capital
letter pi okay so this is equal to v
e x plus v i
x
all right so uh
in the in the next lecture we'll be
talking about uh
the concept of the all-important concept
of strain energy
which will perfect again through all of
our discussions of advanced mechanics of
solids
uh so and
and in general uh mechanics so what
we'll say
now we'll again discuss this but just as
a precursor will uh i just state here
that uh this
this strain energy is associated with uh
certainly with elastic systems
and whatever we have discussed here
uh especially that distinction we made
about
conservativeness in the kinetic sense
and static sense that will come into the
picture
very nicely uh because we'll start our
next discussions
uh with the with the understanding that
a mechanical system
is said to be elastic if the internal
forces
are conservative in the kinetic sense
okay
so that will be the connection between
this lecture and the next lecture
with this understanding which i repeat
that a mechanical system is said to be
conserved
to be elastic if the internal forces are
conservative
in the kinetic sense okay so we'll
continue on with our discussions of
strain energy in the next lecture
thank you very much